[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for tuning in please
hit the Subscribe button today on the
show is Dr John Delani uh here's his new
book building a non-anxious life he is a
number one National bestselling author
mental health and wellness expert host
of the Dr John Delani show which you
need to check out he holds two phds one
in counselor education and supervision
and another in higher education
Administration it was really fun to be
able to dive into mindfulness and
connection and reality being one of them
of like be honest accountability truly
be honest about what's happening in your
life and as Joo would say extreme
ownership learning how to not
necessarily not get rid of anxiety but
how you can craft your world so that
anxiety isn't as much of a part of it or
isn't a part of it anymore and realizing
as he says that anxiety is a smoke
signal it's not the problem it's just
the symptom please enjoy this episode I
hope you like it and please let me know
what you think in the comments and
please share what resonated with you I'd
love to know your place feels so like
like you're at home it's fantastic I am
oh okay well well done well done I
promise I didn't wear the Jelani uniform
today it just so happens that I put
black on and I know you always black I
got your text like hey let's dress this
exactly the same so that was cool I'm in
this will be very cute you make me feel
loved exactly very cute well I think
it's good I feel like I've heard before
that that the reason behind that is like
there I've heard that people that wear
the same thing all the time it's like a
reduction in decisions to make in a day
something like that like it has to do
with sort of brain capacity and just
making fewer decisions is that why you
wear all black all the time mine is this
like latent fantasy that one day this
like really rad punk band is going to
call me and I'm going to be ready at all
times and so I wish it was cuz I was
like into neuroscience but it's really
because I wish I was a punk rock singer
and I ended up a YouTuber and so it's
just me trying to live that out it's for
my high school self you play guitar
right yeah yeah yeah yeah not very well
but I love it yeah oh I'm I'm sure
that's not the case I just want you to
know I have a guitar in the corner way
over here you can't see it and there's
strings broken but I really have high
intentions someday of becoming someone
that can like jam session at night you
know like when the fire is going and
everybody's hanging out after dinner
like little jam session that would be my
goal and you guys like play wonder wall
and have
every know Ben Harper yeah dude well see
that's real good he's really good did
you did your break your strings like
jamming I broke my strings because I
haven't used it and they just sort of I
probably like didn't loosen them when I
flew you know it could have been
something simple like that you just
rocked them off that's cool yeah that
would be much cooler are you I'm so good
I'm so good and you seem so good you
seem very happy yeah we're good we have
like a thousand uh business owners on
campus and so I was just speaking to
that crew and somebody asked me like
about my job and it's like man this is
like a glitch in The Matrix I feel like
we're running a scam here that we get
paid for this and so it's good because
it's so easy and natural yeah yeah I
it's not easy but yeah it's definitely
not the 24/7 of my previous life and so
this is cool I love your show I love I
love that do live callers I feel like
that's so compelling it's a pressure
cooker I'm sure but it's cool cuz you
know it's it's happening real time and
people can plug themselves into those
moments and I feel like those are the
most applicable I love when I hear an
actual story happening because that's
that's where that's where stuff gets
relatable like and people are raw and
you make them get raw like real quick
yeah it's pretty cool and uh my team
intentionally leaves me in the dark on
most of it like I usually get a line or
two and so it's good to I think we have
a a culture that's pretty obsessed with
insta aners and that's just not how our
lives work and to get dropped into to be
honored enough to have somebody reach
out and say hey I don't have anybody
else to call and I don't know you and
you don't know me but I trust you will
you sit with me while I unpack this
that's pretty cool and when I first
started the show I thought that uh I
thought that everybody was coming to me
because I was so smart I was such a
genius and they loved all my genius
answers and I learned really quick
nobody cared about that what they cared
about was they don't have a picture of
what it looks like to sit with somebody
who's hurting and just say I'm sorry
this is awful and let's figure out and
so it's more the model than I think the
answers almost everyone who calls my
show like knows what I'm gonna say I'm
kind of I'm kind of a broken record in
many aspects right like they know what
I'm gon to say they've just never said
it out loud they've never said hey like
I was sexually abused like this happened
or I cheated on my husband again and he
doesn't know how do I tell him like they
know what I'm gonna say like you got to
tell them but they've never said that
out loud and had somebody not wag their
finger at them and i' much mean I just
look around it doesn't work and I'd much
more rather say like we'll pass the
nachos and grab a beer let's figure this
out and I think that's where healing
happens this brings me to this sort of
like little conundrum curiosity because
it makes me want to ask is the healing
all already
initiated before they call because
they're ready to call and they really
know what they're going to what you're
going to say do you think that do you
think that's already like in motion
there's some research that suggest once
you make a call and make an appointment
your body starts lightening up like you
start like you have taken your body now
trusts you that you're driving and like
you I know you've talked to him on your
show like talking to um you know Elite
military guys those dudes don't they get
their heartbeat goes up right but
they've got a gang and they they're
training they're not anxious when
they're out there and because your body
doesn't get anxious if you're driving if
it knows you're in the in the driver's
seat no matter how no pun intended here
right but if you're driving no matter
how Wild the situation is your body is
not going to respond with anxiousness
because you're in the driver's seat it's
when you get put in the backseat of your
own life that your body starts stunning
the alarms and so when you make that
call and you say all right help then
your body's like oh you're driving now
cool we can we can we can get some
support here and so I don't know what I
wish that someone could figure out and
I'm glad that we can't to be honest with
you there's some sort of alchemy it's
woven into every religious system
throughout all of human history this
idea of confession and I think we've
turned it into a tell me all the bad
things you've done that's not the origin
of confession the origin of confession
is yeah me too right like this this is
what happened to me do you still love me
and so I think that's what into all
human history this idea that we got to
say it out loud in front of somebody
else and be heard and know that we're
still loved and I I think that's what
that's what the research does about
about counselors like it doesn't care
what your what Your methodology is it
doesn't care what your background is
when you went to school what matters is
the relationship between those two
people well you ke up on a word that I
love Alchemy it's because when your
inner World changes your outer world the
way you see it changes like we see
things the way we are we don't see
things the way they are and when you
when you make that change inside is that
what you're trying like that's the
Alchemy like you change yourself and
then you change your reality essentially
like you've made that decision and
you've changed something or you've said
I understand that my inside is not
matching reality on the outside I'm
Outsourcing that to you like what do you
see and often a good therapist we like
we tell people when I when I used to be
a grad school Professor I would tell
them like your gift is holding up a
mirror to somebody and letting them know
that you're not going to go anywhere
that you're not running on them like
their dad did like their mom did like
their first four romantic Partners did
you're here and there's just a gift in
that but like when I get anxious and
when I get I get worked up I'm a lot my
wife tells me like when I get worked up
um I know that my frontal lobe goes
offline I'm not gonna make the most
rational decisions and so often I
Outsource that I got a couple of men in
my life that have been ride or die for
years and I and say hey I got this issue
am I seeing this right and they'll be
like know you [__] like that person
gave you a great response why are you
act and so I think that's important to
know when I can be in touch with my
inner reality and and help it change my
external reality and also
know I don't think my insides are
matching reality on the outside I'm G to
get some support here so the conundrum
part that I was saying earlier is like I
I think that there's already Something
In Motion you say yes there's something
happening but the problem I don't the
heart it's going to be hard work look
it's like the going through the
emotional Alchemy the the actual
changing of the patterns that is hard
[__] like really hard um and it feels
wrong because it's not normal so it
feels really really wrong but the real
question is how do you get to the point
that you you you want to do that like
that's the hard part the hard part yes
it's going to be emotional it's going to
be difficult
but like the actual part I always tell
people when you know they talk to me and
if they have difficult things going on
I'm like the fact that you're where you
are you've literally taken 48 years to
get to this point you're so close now
the most painful part is left but like
you've come so far so like how do you
get to come so far to not be so
far I I mean I think we've tried a great
experiment by
making uh education mandatory I think we
tried to put information in people's
heads and for some that works I mean we
could get super nerdy here but we're on
the back end of the Enlightenment where
I what the best way we can know
something truly is to take it apart to
all of its pieces and learn everything
about each individual piece and what I
need to do is I can learn about each
individual piece and then I'm going to
put that inside your head and then
you're going to know me I'm going to
tell you you're going to learn about all
the things I've said all the things I've
done and all of the fill-in the blank
and then you'll know me and now we are
learning oh the individual pieces you
can spread out I can spread out a
motorcycle engine and learnning about
each one of the pieces that doesn't
teach me what a combustion engine how it
works I don't know how it works right
and so what we're finding is it's not
the individual pieces it's the
interaction between all the pieces all
at the same time and so the in I can
learn about a bunch of individual people
and dude they act differently when
they're in a mosh pit when they're in a
mob right that's just it's a different
animal and so I think we had this
obsession with if I can just learn all
the rules or I tell my my mental health
students
like we've lied to people we told them
mental health is just all the right
thoughts in the right order and that's
not true that's not mental health mental
health is a an entire infinity loop of
your body and your relationships and
your spiritual life and your systems
that you're thrown in in your
environment and the thoughts that you
think right so it's all of it all
together and so
ultim it's an old tro but I think it's
right when the price of when the pain of
staying the same is perceived to be less
than the pain of change I think that's
when it happens and for some of us you
can see your older brother get arrested
and you can go I don't ever want to feel
like that and so I'm gonna not drink I'm
gonna not get in fights or whatever some
people see their friend cheat on their
wife and they're like man that blew up
his whole life I guess I'll probably get
away with it right then they got to go
through it themselves elves and so I
think I wish we could just teach
somebody and here's a road map and I
think that's what education's good for
but on the back end I think there's
there's therapists on the back end for
I'll sit with you when you blow up your
whole life and I wish I wish I I wish
there was an answer to that but I think
that Trope is right when the pain
of when the pain of being 100 pounds
overweight becomes harder than the hell
it's going to be to lose 100 pounds I
think that's the that's the that's the
magic have you found that everyone's
threshold is very different very
different very different what do you
think dictates
that probably a probably a cosmic gumbo
of genetics and what you grew up with
and experiences you had and whether you
were resilient when you experienced
trauma a versus trauma B I mean I think
it's a whole bunch I can I can on a on a
light level I can see my kids and say
hey kids
let's only eat marshmallows for dinner
and let's sit around a campfire out at
our place and let's camp out in the
front yard and let's get up really early
and go hiking and then let's eat
marshmallows for for lunch my wife has
an ability to see to four o'clock the
next afternoon when all the kids have
melted down and they're screaming and
crying and running around I literally
can't see that I can't project it I'll
just say like hey that's a problem for
future John we figure it out then and
she's like yeah I'm usually the one has
to figure that out and so I have a very
short term this would be so fun right
now and she has a very long term and
this is what it's going to cost us and
so I think I need people in my life on
one end and she can also find herself
going to bed at 8 o'clock surrounded by
lists without any Adventure right and so
I think that's where you you other
people are really important in our lives
anxiety is fascinating to me because and
I like how you start off like in the
book it's for every every kind of
anxiety because when I think about it
I'm like
I feel very fortunate that I'm not
someone that that suffers from anxiety
because and I know that because I've
only had it a few times and I know that
because I've felt it it's almost like
and it's like when you ask somebody if
they've had an orgasm and they're like I
don't know it's like then no no you you
know you know exactly and so like I've
I've experienced it like three or four
times which is not much and I'm really
really grateful for that because when I
did it was like oh I know what this is I
can escape this spiral I'm spiraling I'm
I can't choose a good thought right now
it's like I have a super heightened
anxiet like super heightened like body
function like heart rates going up and
like I'm I'm I felt it and so so I'm
very curious about anxiety and what what
really brings it what really makes it
part of someone's life especially in a
chronic way I'm very curious about
childhood from that perspective but I do
love how you say that it's a smoke
signal people want to cure anxiety but
that's just the symptom let me back out
real quick so I want to ask
you how does your body get your
attention you know it's something I've
had to learn how to get more in touch
with in fact as a mini story I was just
at the gym with my friend this morning
and the the trainer she had never been
there so she was just coming to visit me
and he asked her how she was feeling how
many reps how many more reps could you
do and she's like I don't know and so we
come from a CrossFit background where it
was just like this is what you do here's
the clock that's it it doesn't matter
what the hell your body tells you and so
I we're driving home and I'm like well
that's because we're used to not being
tuned into the body at all like all you
have to do is just like I'll do anything
so I'm sure if he had told you to do 20
more you would have if he told you to do
two you would have and so getting in
tune and in touch with the body is
something that I had to learn probably
you know five years ago and so how does
it get my attention I mean I can feel it
in my gut I can feel tightness yeses are
full body goosebumps you know the I'm
feeling it in my body and the yes is in
the nose what does it do in times of
stress does it it it doesn't amp you up
which is an anxiousness it doesn't spin
you out and try to solve problems 30
miles down the road does it does it pull
you down actually get getting tired is a
common one ah there you go yeah yeah a
conversation started about a decade ago
and I was at some nerd conference and
just surrounded like just nerds hanging
out with Nerds and somebody's walking
through the genetics of ADHD and at the
time they we thought we had won the
lottery and like oh it's a genetic
disorder and the presenter wisely said
hey by the way genetics will explain a
piece of this but you can't just say
this is genetic because that's not how
genetics work everybody didn't didn't
all get this at the same time and that
as I left I remember thinking because I
was just melted with an anxiety just
just decimated with it and by the way my
parents are still married the 50-some
years my dad was a policeman and like a
SWAT guy in in Houston my mom's a
brilliant Professor uh my wife loved me
most of the time I had a healthy kid
like I have no business on paper having
anxiety silly right and I remember
leaving and it was the first time the
thought entered my mind what if my
body's working
perfectly what if this anxiety what if
the ADHD which the body's response to
chaos what if
fatigue your body's like Hey we're
getting out of here and we're going to
wrap it up into something that you will
digest which is sleep let's just go to
bed let's just let's just we think of
fighting and fleeing we think of fleeing
as running and screaming fleeing is
often just turn the Netflix on turn it
kind of quiet and get under the covers
right so what if our bodies are working
perfectly what would that say about the
world we've created when everyone has
everything you can push a button on your
cell phone and food just shows up at
your house evolutionarily that's Madness
right you can go in a bathroom and turn
a knob and water comes out that's
Madness right we've solved for
everything and you could punch a button
and communicate with a million people
right now evolutionary that's insane and
our bodies are more depressed and more
exhausted and more anxious than in
recorded human history what what gives
and so I'm somebody who began to work
back backwards what is anxiety doing in
your body and in your brain oh dude this
just trying to get our attention anxiety
work means most of the time our bodies
are working pretty damn well so I have
to ask a way harder question which is
not Hey how do I shut this alarm system
off but what is happening in my life to
set this alarm off and that means I have
had to have hard conversations with my
wife like are we gonna stay married I've
had to ask myself am I going to stay at
this job I've had to ask myself that's
time to change careers I can't hang out
with these people I got to quit drinking
I got whatever the things are in your
life those are way harder than just
climbing up in your kitchen and pulling
the batteries out of your smoke detector
right do you believe that everyone has
to address essentially traumas and
childhood to like make that step forward
to figuring things out and why they are
not able to process certain things or
why they have certain reactions why
they're triggered in certain ways
because that all leads to more anxiety I
always hesitate when I'm talking about
health or or emotional health or mental
health to say the word always everybody
but I haven't yet met that person right
who doesn't have some stories I like to
be careful with and I don't want to be
over dramatic but with language like
figure out or solve because I don't want
to treat my body like a Law and Order
SVU unit uh episode right I would prefer
to just and this is just recent for me
man if I'm curious versus trying to
figure out what the hell's going on here
it's just the Cascade of my response
both in my body and my relationships how
I treat my kids and my co-workers
everything's just different if I start
getting angry every time my wife comes
in the room and I try to figure it out
what I'm gonna figure out is that she's
causing this otherwise if I ask myself
huh how come every time she walks in my
body starts to defend itself I need to
get to the bottom of that then that's a
very like that's a that's a gentle way
of saying let's figure this out same as
if my seven-year-old daughter she's like
living with a blender without the top on
she's a human hurricane dude she's
incredible and if she does something
goofy I can yell and scream I can be
like I'm figuring this out and she will
I'll just I'll Crush her or I can sit
down and go dude what happened she's
like I squeezed the lizard and now it's
not a lie like one is very compassionate
and very like let's get to the bottom
and one is very like Law and Order right
let's solve this thing and so yeah I've
got to figure out why does my body um
sound the alarms when my wife comes in
she loves me I love her I need to pull a
string on that and I'm going to gently
walk it back over a couple years and
figure out dude what is my body trying
to protect me from when this person I
care about walks in the door oh maybe
when I was a child it was my job when
Dad got home was probably good for me
just to just to hide just to be small
just to disappear you have the ability
to do that most people don't have that
level of awareness of
like maybe it's the you know like most I
mean I similar like I had a great
childhood my parents are still married
like you know I we wanted for nothing so
I don't think it's as easy as going I
think the first step is like okay why is
my body what is my body telling me and
right then and there I don't think most
anybody is tuned into really how their
body feels do you agree that's exactly
right 100% And we we um you may have
heard me say this in other places like
we have something called that they they
so gratuitously call it the attention
economy that's stupid it's the
distraction anything I can do to pull
you apart from how your body feels I
need to get keep you in your head and
let you know that you are missing
something that I need to sell you or
you're missing something that I can fix
for you at the political level as as
further away as I can get you from your
body and from your close inner gang your
tribe the better I my business is going
to be the better my political angle is
going to be so yes 1,00% and I also
think this I think we I think often you
act your way into you reverse engineer
your way into some of these these
thoughts and so you're right most people
most of the time like just yell when
they get pissed off or when that guy
cuts them off off in traffic you just
yell like or you just grab the wheel and
so sometimes it's best when I'm sitting
with somebody okay we're just gonna
start there stop acting like don't yell
never yell in your house ever and if you
do catch yourself yelling stop in the
middle of it and walk outside so I'm GNA
put these action breaks I think we live
in our heads too much just act right and
then that creates some space between
what you were about to do and what you
decided to not do stop spending
money give your partner your your your
Amazon login and you don't know how to
get into it and every time you go to buy
something stop and that's the Gap to go
dude what was I about to buy why was I
about to click on that and so I think
sometimes you can just reverse engineer
it and create a list of action I'm gonna
quit doing this thing I won't smoke well
of course you're gonna you can't just
like declare it like Michael Scott like
I declare bankruptcy you can't do that
but I can say I'm gonna quit smoking and
then every time I go to do it what am I
what is my body trying to protect me
from right now I and I think that's a
good way to find that Gap like what is a
practice someone could do to get into
their body a little bit and feel
something this is a very unpopular
answer but I had to Outsource it I had
to ask my wife I had to ask a couple of
my buddies I had to ask a
counselor I don't want
to like for me I I've struggled body
image issues my whole life body
dismorphia forever and eat mindlessly
and so I've never struggled with alcohol
I've never struggled with like doing
drugs but dude I just like I like to rub
gummy candies on my face like I'm pour
them down my shirt like I just love it
dude and so but I eat mindlessly and
especially when I have relationship
issues I just eat I just eat and eat and
eat and eat and I get real Angry I've
got anger issues and so I would ask like
my wife hey if you see me
just just ask hey are you really hungry
and she does it very gently when it
first started it was very accusational
and I was like it really like it didn't
go well but she will just ask hey um
that's the ninth marshmallow are you are
you hungry and I'll go ah I should
probably quit eating Mar you know what I
mean it's like uh but I I I wish I could
say I was just like Snapp it to a slim
gym but I asked people who love and care
about me to quietly hold me accountable
and just gently ask like hey man were
you so mad dude your jaw is clinched are
you angry at somebody and I'll be like
oh dude I was I was Crea imaginary
stories about what I was going to tell
my boss in my head and I was running on
Loop didn't even think about it and so
then next time maybe I catch my jaw
clinching up or maybe next time I catch
myself reaching into the the Jelly Bean
Bowl but we hey we've we've dude we have
lied to ourselves as though we can do
all this crap by ourself you can't we
the human body is not designed to run
this whole thing alone it just not and
it's a it's a lie and so I have to have
other people in my life walking
alongside being like like hey there's a
hole there you're about to step in again
and I have to say dude thank you so much
for for seeing in the road where I
couldn't see well it's this beautiful
reality that people are a mirror for us
always especially if they love you and
you have your best interest at heart
right and you know as well as I do
there's people who like to walk
alongside you so they can say they're
walking alongside you or people who walk
alongside you because they might get
something out of it and I think that's
part of some folks journey is to get
those people out of your life um but
yeah if people love you they'll hold a
mirror up to you and like a therapist
earlier they won't leave they'll be
there but even the practice of letting
someone be the mirror for yourself
meaning like when I get into a situation
if I have a reaction I know that I have
a part in it like I have been triggered
somehow and so like in my head I'm going
okay what's my part in this like why did
I react like that what am I afraid of if
I would if I of of the situation what
would I have what was I afraid of what
would I what's the story I'm telling
myself so like we don't even actually
need someone always to tell us something
we can use them as a mirror for
ourselves that's mentorship somebody
walked alongside you along the way and
said well like you may be with some
girlfriends you be like can you believe
this person broke up with me and they
can be like yeah cuz you treated them
like that and you're like me right and
so over time that's mentorship that's
iron sharpens iron and then later on
you're able to go yeah I I I can feel
myself getting hot I'm just gonna let
this person my partner know I need I
need to cool off right and I think over
time yeah you you get released to the
wild that way that's just maturity
that's just growing up I think was
wisdom I would call it maybe
spirituality or like quantum physics or
like trying to understand the nature of
reality and for me that's also been
super helpful Dynamic just to go oh wow
like am I creating my world and like and
like am I you know am I we are all our
own little universe and I am just sort
of seeing myself through everybody I
mean I think so when you're talking
about some of the you know having that
pause moment and being able to go okay
maybe I shouldn't do that or maybe I
reacted a little bit like that's that's
a that's like a steps along part of the
process that's that's being mindful
which I know is one of those six daily
choices like that's mindfulness and that
is that takes a long time oh yeah dude
I'm 10 years in to yeah exactly so this
is it takes a lot of practice but my
hope is that people can see it man it
doesn't diminish from my fun and my just
being a goofball and it doesn't diminish
from my professional life or my academic
life or whatever or my marriage but man
it sure makes my metabolic Health better
it stops all that rumination and drama
that I just I was bathing in all the
time I'm just sort of fascinated by that
how do you get like I would call it more
of the Observer perspective like how do
you get above the situation like what
are some ways that you've done that like
instead of being something happens in
you're in it that was what I that was
what I how I describe you're in it
you're triggered you're somebody did
this it's their fault and then how do
you get above it um I think a couple
things one is I worked for 15 years to
create a life where I remained out of
The Fray as best as possible I grew up
with a policeman for Dad and we didn't I
mean there was Seasons when I don't know
if you know like they just don't pay
cops anything and so there was Seasons
when we didn't have grocery I mean there
was tough Seasons um and so for 15 years
my wife and I worked coming from nothing
and then going to college because that's
what you're supposed to do and ran up a
whole bunch of student loans and
whatever like and her parents were
Elementary School teachers and so like
we worked for 15 years to not owe
anybody anything and so I don't have to
get into it for survival right and it's
not that we're rich it's just that like
we made peace with the Corolla life dude
we made peace with used cars and what
that gave us was dude y I'm like I don't
even have to go to fight because I don't
I don't have a dog in it right like you
can watch you can just slowly remove
yourself or I went to counseling to
figure out man why do I care that much
what people think oh because I'm so
desperate for people I don't have two
phds because I'm super smart I have two
phds because I've been begging since I
was a little kid do you see me and think
I'm smart too because I had a brilliant
sister and a savant little brother and
so I wanted to not just be the dumb jock
and so I've been begging people to say
I'm smart too and so once I unhooked
from that and it's like man I don't care
anymore then suddenly I don't have to
get I don't have a stake in that fight I
don't have to get into all those fights
and so for me it's been less about how
do I solve it when I'm in the middle of
it because if I wait till I'm in the
middle of it then I'm in the middle of
it it's how can I remove gently or
sometimes systematically over time the
need to even participate in it one of
the most powerful things my therapist
told me years ago was no one holds the
keys there you
go but that's Al that's a terrifying
thought right oh that's exactly what I
said I started crying and I was like I
was like that's heavy that's a lot and
she's like well you don't have to do it
alone you have me you have people you
have people that you can lean on but
like no one can just tell you I'm sorry
and you'll feel better no it's not how
it works because you've got family
you've got genetics you've got history
you've got too much too much in that
machine that already gets kicked off
down the road once that thing happens
right and so I'm gonna get all the way
on the front end of it and the I think
we have a culture I even in the book I
didn't write a bunch of strategies for
how to deal with it when you have
anxiety how to deal with it when you're
panicked all right that book's out there
there's a million of that book out there
there's a million blog posts about that
I'm way more interested in how do I
create a life so that my alarms aren't
ringing all the time how do I create
relationships so that I can
identify a leech when I see it or I can
I can see a train wreck coming before
I'm in the middle of it and that's just
intentionality and quite honestly it's
probably the same way if somebody came
up to you and said like hey I want to
get into driving how do I do that you
would be like you got to practice and so
I think thinking about controlling my
thoughts and thinking about unhooking
myself from these systems and thinking
about dude I'm feeling myself getting
geared up I'm G practice de-escalating I
think over time it just becomes second
nature right it just becomes part of
your nervous system if you work at it
just like anything else we work at do
you think there are
archetypal trauma
patterns in people
question I I I mean there's nervous
system responses there's fight flight
and freeze and fawning and I mean so
yeah I think there's probably like not
like not enough or not you know like
like some core fundamental issues like I
don't feel worthy or I don't feel like
I'm enough or I'm I'm uh worthless or
you know there's like some core kind of
do you think that there are just like
core trauma patterns within people
narratives maybe better word yeah I mean
I think Yun talks about the the stories
right just those those common narratives
that run through all of civilization I
tend to take a more evolutionary
psychology approach which
is if your tribe leaves you you're
probably going to die so wired into us
at the DNA level is this I have to
belong and belonging means I have to
shut down part of myself so that you'll
still love me and so that you won't
leave and so that you won't leave our
romantic partnership and go with that
guy in our tribe and so I think it's as
simple as that
as at the core of it is do you really
know me all the dark stuff do you know
me and the good stuff and do you still
love me I think it all the nervous
system response comes from that place
because we don't we we can't we can't be
left and you talked about not we're not
meant to do this alone do you think that
because the way that societ operates now
is hopefully a two two parent home but
many times not and not any not even that
much more right like it used to be a
community there was Grandma there was
Grandpa there was aunts and uncles there
was cousins and like it was really
community-like and if you track back
further in history even more so like it
was like this is there's tribe mentality
like do you think that's part of why we
are so because we we essentially what
I'm kind of going towards is like um we
have to shut down so many things so that
we can be so we survive so that we have
food and a shelter and so we shut down
so many parts of it because we just
literally have to like adapt to the one
person so like there's so many things
that have to shut down where if we had
eight people that took care of us in a
big way we would be able to be ourselves
in many of those places like we wouldn't
have to shut so many parts of us down
because this one imprint has to happen
to survive do you think that's a big
part of our problem in society no
question about it yeah you nailed it
we've created the loneliest generation
in human history yeah and we're
surrounded by people and Estep Perell
talks about this really
eloquently we just expect this other
person that we get married to or we
decide to do life to they have to be
everything they have to be a co- earner
they have to be hot and we have to keep
having sex until we're 95 we they have
to be um like the perfect dinner
companion they have to laugh at all my
jokes they have to think all the will
Ferell movies are funny or not funny
they have to like sefel or not like
Seinfeld of course they are but they
like they have to be everything and she
talks so beautifully about that used to
be res like part of that that was the
job of the church and part of that that
was the job of your grandparents and
part of that that was the CH the charge
of the men in the tribe and this is the
part of the women and you just dump all
that on that one person of course they
leave or of course they melt right and
so how do you create a marriage with in
this new system that we've done how do
you create a Partnerships and
relationships and I remember early
on trying to I was I mean I just didn't
know how to be married I didn't know
what we were doing we got married really
young my wife and I and I remember
thinking like it's
unfair to put all of this on one person
she can't think everything I think is
funny and like punk music and want to go
listen to me talk about track times I
was all I was a track and field coach
and dude I used should watch your eyes
roll on the back of her head when I was
re running off splits she was like I
can't tell you how little I care about
the split times of your 4x4 relay team
and at first I was like you don't love
me you don't know me because it's
important to me so it should be
important to you not should it has to be
you and I have that's Madness right it's
insane and so it becomes a negotiation
of no I know this is important to you so
I'm going to sit through the track me
you get one right and I'll go to one
punk rock show with you and you got to
go see George straight with me and so it
just became this incredible enrichment
right and I'm not threatened anymore by
hey I think I'm gonna go get my master
gardener certification well that sounds
incredible I'm going hunting right and
we can both go that go our separate ways
but we're still anchored into the same
place but yeah I think you're you nailed
it we are ask it's a big experiment and
it doesn't seem to be going well which
is what if one person is responsible for
all of this what if two people are
responsible for all of this and I'll
I'll say this I'll go on record saying
this if you're doing this by yourself if
you are trying to do it all work
full-time raise a family be an advocate
in your community do retirement you know
have a nice car have hobbies have
friends if your body recognizes your out
there
alone and by the way you can be crowd
you can be lonely in a crowd room right
we all know that you can be infinitely
lonely at a table surrounded by loved
ones
right your body would be failing you if
it let you sleep all night it'd be
failing you it would be failing you if
it let you have a deep connected
intimate sexual relationship with your
wife or your husband because your body's
trying to not die because you're all you
got and so we try to solve all these
external things all these proxies we're
trying to change the bulbs in the
dashboard on our car that doesn't put
gas in the car right so I've got to look
at my life what am I expecting my body
to do when I put it in this precarious
situation that way and that means I
gotta do something really that really
sucks and that's go make friends as an
adult and that's the worst right I gotta
go make Community I got to go be weird
and vulnerable and we just don't have
any tools for
that you said the word lonely and and
you said you know how it's easy to be
lonely even at a table full of people
that love
you and I'm curious about that because
even from my own experience
I've never actually been lonely by
myself the only time I've been lonely is
in a relationship before tell me about
that why is that um well that's the only
time I've actually felt lonely and where
is that from where does that stem from I
I would say not being chosen that's what
it feels like to me that not being
Chosen and it it's actually like and
probably what it really is is I have so
deeply abandoned my own self to be in
this situation that I am separate from
myself in the biggest way when I'm alone
I'm I I'm it's not somebody's not
choosing me I'm choosing myself I'm
honoring myself and my what I want to do
each day and what I need to do and what
makes me better and and and my interests
but in a relationship when it's not the
right one and there and and and and
there's Discord that's it's difficult I
am actually abandoning Myself by staying
in it and I think that's probably why
I've felt the most lonely in
relationships yeah you said that
beautifully like a simpler way I would
say abandoning self is keeping secrets
when I have to hide part of myself so
that the story I tell myself is I gotta
hide this part of me so that you won't
leave that always ends in Ash and I
think the signal is your body saying hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa you're completely
alone here you're holding this dude's
hand and you are walking in a place that
you said you wanted to be together
but you're keeping secrets you're not
telling the truth you're not being whole
and the fear is he's GNA go and I think
that yeah that never plays out but I
think we I mean who are we most scared
of is going to leave us our family and
so we don't talk politics because I
don't want that guy to storm off and I
don't want her to get all mad and so I
just be quiet and we don't have we
haven't created a space where it's okay
for you and me to believe different
things or to think different things at
your table and so then I go out and
curate Echo chamber friends and who just
believe all the same things and we do
all the same things and that's a good
proxy but man when you're surrounded by
people that you love you know what's at
stake they might go and that's the hope
is you see me and you might roll your
eyes right my mom saw my first tattoo
one time she was like oh my gosh are you
serious and then she's like let me see
like let me see and I know my mom still
love me right so it's it's it's you're
not going anywhere and what the most
interesting thing is is that a lot of
times it's when we are the most
comfortable and we share the most with
someone that we end up being loved the
most for all of those things but we
don't want to show it to the person
we're afraid to lose why is
that I wonder if you're talking about
quantum physics and knowing I I wonder
if we know I wonder if we know like on a
subconscious ortic level that guy's not
safe she's not safe and you you know you
you ever find yourself talking to
somebody and minutes in you're like I've
been this person forever and 30 minutes
in you're like having conversations and
you're like oh my gosh my boyfriend
doesn't know this um I think your body
goes I feel safe this one's okay and I I
think that's something to listen to in
honor I really do and I the joke um when
I was 18 I went to this like class and
they were like when you go to college
you're gonna strip all of your beliefs
from you and they're going to like
corrupt you so write down the 10 things
that you're your future spouse has to
have and I was like oh yeah and I wrote
him down and we just went just finished
21 years of being married and my wife
had two of the 10 that I wrote down I
was 18 man I wasn't even close not I
mean not it was just so stupid but
here's what was important I kept coming
back to yeah she doesn't have this and
she doesn't like this and I like this
but she doesn't like that
and but dude when we were together my
body felt
safe and and it never occurred to me
that's where you start building from
y'all are anchored into the same value
system believe different stuff who cares
are you anchored into the same values
and that's a different that's a
different place to start body's keeping
the score all the time all day long yeah
all day long do you find that is there
is there common problems with men and
common problems with women like that are
separate when comes to what are the most
common like when it comes to like
anxiety yeah
um you know Terry reel Terence reel is
just he wrote the most important book of
the last 20 years I think I don't want
to talk about it that's the name of the
book by the way
oh clever I don't want talk about it um
but he was the first person I ever saw
pull apart the statistics in a way that
was real eye- opening for me because if
you look at the Diagnostics women are
way more depressed than men women are
way more anxious than men they're
diagnosed with those things more they go
to therapy for those things more
and he was the first person I ever saw
that said no it's just that women
Express anxiety this way or depression
this way men puff their chest up and go
punch somebody Men drink a lot to shut
the alarm systems off they do drugs to
shut the alarm systems off they run and
so if you look at prison populations and
you look at violent
crime and you lay that over the mental
health Diagnostics of women now you get
a more equal picture and so I think men
and women experience it differently like
when it comes to ADHD boys little boys
will act bananas girls often will shut
the whole system down um so I think yeah
there's some there's some
differentiation I just got to a point
where I don't like to think
diagnostically anymore I like to sit
with somebody and say what's your body
trying to protect you from and it might
protect you from getting loud it might
protect you by getting real quiet but
let's just start there man the labels
can be helpful for insurance companies
and sometimes for Nam of the Dragon but
man I'm way more interested in
how you trying to protect yourself when
I got one kid bouncing off the walls and
I get one kid who just goes into neutral
in school and then gets in the car and
it's back to bouncing off the walls that
tells me ah your body's telling you that
that system isn't safe that environment
is not safe let's start
there then what do you do because
there's going to be some pretty
fundamental problems with people if they
are not safe in a situation like with
their partner like I mean you're about
to rock their world yeah and that's
that's the um I think going back to the
distraction economy I think
that many of us have a reality Reckoning
either happening to us right now or it's
on its way or it has happened because
you can get all the money in the world
and you're gonna get that phone call
from your mom that says honey I got
cancer you're gonna borrow money and
borrow money and borrow money and you
just think you're just going to keep
getting that bonus your sales numbers
are just going to keep hitting that
sales numbers and then one day you don't
and the government's going to tell you
hey we're GNA bail you out and then they
don't right or you're just going to get
I just need to get that degree from that
place and I don't care what it costs
I'll just borrow it because I'll pay it
off later it doesn't right and so I
think there is a you got to deal with
reality and you can have
the the home and as we talked earlier
and you can shut down half your system
trying to keep that thing that facade of
that thing going uh and that's how
family trauma rolls down generation to
generation is your kids absorb that
tension of you holding down Who You Are
and they think oh dude it's I'm doing
that to my mom I'm doing that to my dad
and they try to solve it and then they
end up in that same pattern over and
over and over again and it takes
somebody saying you know I've spoken a
lot my with my wife there was a couple
of times over 21 years where we've sat
across a table like grown-ups and said
are we GNA keep doing this and if it's
time for us to call it then we're going
to be adults and we're going to figure
out what that means but we can't keep
doing this thing we call marriage like
this
and I hope you don't want to go because
I don't but I can't keep doing this so
we had to build something completely new
and then we had to build something new
again they we had to build something new
again and so I think that's the that's
the event right but I think what you
said you're gonna rock their world
you're damn right we are and I think a
whole whole whole lot of people need to
have the world rocked because they're
they're living in a world that's not
real I want to go through the uh the six
daily choices and I picked a I've come
up with a question for each category and
I kind of want you to like articulate at
each um what you mean by it because when
you just say the word it's maybe not
enough I want to hear from your
perspective what you mean by it so with
choose choose reality like when you say
real like explain your explain the
thought behind
that like there's there's something
important about the exercise of getting
quiet and writing down on a piece of
paper what is the state of my
marriage what is the state of my dating
relationship what's the state of my
health I'm looking at a panel here or
how overweight am I how underweight am I
um what's the state of my job like being
honest about where you actually are not
on either side of the it's all coming
down no it's not or oh it's all G to be
the same no no it's not right there's
something about sitting down and owning
reality and earlier we were talking
about when your body is knows you're
driving then it doesn't need to sound
the alarms because you're in control
it's when you're separate from reality
when you're in the backseat of your own
life somebody else is running your life
for you that your body tries to get your
attention so there's something important
about sitting with your partner sitting
with a couple of close friends you trust
and saying hey my kid walks in the front
door every day and just slams the door
and goes in their room oh those
teens no that's not right it's not true
it's not reality let's own reality your
kid does not feel safe in the room with
you or does not like you does not want
to be in the room with we got to deal
with that let's deal with that why is it
that people have such a hard time being
accountable what is what is the most
common story people tell themselves
about what it means if
they admit to being falling short or
admit to not being good at something or
not knowing what to do like why is it
that it's so hard to be accountable yeah
that's I mean that's the whole culture
we've created that if you're
uncomfortable it's somebody else's fault
I just don't think we have a psychology
for it I think that's when jao said take
ownership I think I mean people's eyes
bugged out of their heads you mean just
stand in front of my boss and say I was
I made the call and I was
wrong and it's
like why why would anyone do that and it
without understanding that's the path to
freedom and I mean look at the political
if somebody would stand up and say I
made a call and I blew it and here's
what I'm doing to make it right I think
that person would just be escorted into
the office the next election on a you
know what I mean with because you'd
actually believe them when they said
they did do something the problem is
with not being able to be honest is that
you never believe when they're you don't
know when they're right and if you at
least say look [__] up man that's me
that's me on me or like you know and
then also they'll know like hey get it
together you're not you know I need you
to do this and then when they say good
job or when you've done something really
well like it it conveys TR honesty it's
true it makes everything else true when
you say when something is essentially
off or wrong or you could have done
better but I don't think we have a
psychology of blame if you're
uncomfortable it's somebody else's fault
find out who that is you are perfect and
you get to construct truth as you go
along you get to make it up as you go
which is different than I've got my own
internal reality that I'm experiencing
right we talked about that but I think
you have to Simply blow that out of
water but I don't think people have a
psychology for it because it's like
seriously just gonna sit in front of my
wife and say hey dude I just yelled a
couple hours ago and that was that was I
shouldn't have done that do you think
they just feel Justified though do you
think it's just that they just no I
think justification comes as your body
it's it's that's a defense mechanism to
let you sleep at night I don't think
people usually are internally Justified
but here's the thing I get to create the
story that's the beauty of it that guy
cuts me off in traffic I can just flip
him off and be like you piece of crap
like you just doing drugs you stupid
Millennial and your dumb dropped Honda
Civic [__] I can do that or he can cut
me off listening to and I can exhale and
say God please help this dude get to the
hospital for his wife dies none of those
stories are going to impact that dude at
all zero none of them his life is going
on the way he's going on one of those is
going to give me a stroke and one of
those is going to bring me towards peace
and a little closer to empathy and a
little more love why would I choose the
other story so I get to make that up but
if I start seeking justification dude
that's a recipe for burning everybody
you love to the ground choosing
connection I love this yeah I mean it's
what we talked about we've created the
loneliest generation and we've been told
we can do it ourselves and it's just
it's Madness it's insane what is it that
we subconsciously fear with these deep
connections and
vulnerability what's the story We Tell
ourselves there well I think on one end
I think we have accidentally I don't
think we've gotten lonely on purpose I
think that's purely accidental I think
we talk to our friends via text and we
have those hilarious long text threads
of emojis and funny gifts and memes that
are just
awesome and 80 to 90% of communication's
non-verbal and I think our bodies are
screaming at us that we're alone but
we've outsourced it all to a bunch of
zeros and ones and so we're only
communicating with 10 to 20% of black
and white text and I I I could text my
wife a hundred times today I love you
and you're beautiful but her body
doesn't register until she sees my eye
crinkles and she sees me drop my
shoulders and she feels me grab her and
hug her like in mean it right then her
body feels loved and safe not just I
love you I love you and then I walk in I
think I told you a hundred times today
via text and then I just grab a drink
and go up and watch you know TV yeah
dude that's not connection right yeah
technology satisfies who where what when
and how but not not but it doesn't give
you the connection to be seen and
experienced like the seen and experience
connection is that and experienced is a
beautiful word for vulnerability well
that's your words I'm just I'm just
wrote down what you said what you wrote
I thought you said that I didn't I
didn't think I said that vulnerability
will get you killed that's that's what
sucks that's why your body fights you on
it'll get you killed
and it's the only path towards truly
being safe with somebody and truly being
able to drop your shoulders and that's I
mean that's the elite military guys they
go around the room and say what did I do
good in that mission what did I screw up
in that mission what am I gonna do
different next time that's vulnerability
right I got you implies you're gonna get
faced with a situation that you don't
see the full picture I got you that's
vulnerability telling your husband or
your
boyfriend I blew it last night I'm
sorry they might say and I'm out and
that's you being vulnerable and you're
getting killed or they might say thank
you so much right and
that's there's no way forward look
around man being all the tough guy stuff
just doesn't it just doesn't work okay
the next one with choose choose Freedom
such an interesting word I've
experienced throughout time go ahead
with a choose choosing freedom I think I
wrote in there that it's not like about
American flag underwear and like PE PE
and the eagle like like that's not what
I mean I'm talking about the nerd word
is agency or autonomy and who is telling
me what I'm going to do every day and if
you owe money to a car dealership then
Ford Motor Company is telling you what
you will do tomorrow I'm sick and I
can't go to work you're going to work
because you're gonna pay me or the
mortgage company and so people push back
and they're like oh so I'm just not
supposed to owe anybody money exactly ex
L then that might mean you got to make
make make peace with a Ford tourist life
because you're an assistant director of
Technology at a local middle school
that's amazing those kids need
you and you're not going to be able to
fully show up if you have to have a 20
25 Yukon or whatever that cost 100,000
bucks that you can barely make the
payment on and your brain can't let you
sleep because it knows if you do one
thing and get laid off you lose your
house you lose your car you lose your
food
and so when I say choose Freedom I'm
talking about from clutter I'm talking
about from chaotic insane calendars that
if one thing gets five minutes over your
whole week Falls over talking about
freedom from owing people money I'm
talking about just unhooking yourself
from the Matrix of being able to say
what is best for me and my family in
this upcoming season what do I want to
do who do I want to be and I'm gonna
start with that question not who do I
got to pay what do I have to do creating
your own life for yourself you being the
you being the designer instead of being
the robot the puppet or the respondant
yeah I've once heard that in a
relationship men need to feel free is
that true like is like as a like a some
kind of I was going to ask you about the
types of freedom but I was just curious
about this like like they need to feel
like they can be whoever they are and do
whatever they want like that is like a
core like male need I've never heard
that I don't have that no
no I I
want that was [__] man I want a core
purpose and a reason for being and I
want people to serve and I want to know
that my wife is really proud of me and
I've got to live into that so almost the
opposite of whoever told you that yeah
well it didn't work out
so that sounds like a dude who wants to
hook up with other people while he's
dating the same person that's what that
sounds like no like every man's got to
be free like all right whatever and then
if you don't care then I'll like you
more that seems like an unhealthy
relationship yeah it's not safe that's
stupid how is mind like how is it that
mindfulness is a different way of I
think you said a different way of
learning and living and experiencing the
world like what is it about mindfulness
that's so much different what is new
about it you're choosing to be
intentional and curious not reactionary
and judgmental so you're ch using to
enter into a room and you go into talk
to your sponsors and you can feel the
tension they're going to give you some
tough news you can feel
it and instantly your defense mechanisms
kick in and you start talking too much
or you start shutting down or you start
getting kind of pissed off that's
reactionary and then the moment they're
like hey we're hitting a rough patch
with we're going to pull the rip cord on
this sponsorship in the next six months
and you instantly go into judgment oh
because you guys can't freaking run your
right instantly into it or mindfulness
is a long-term practice it's not some
old dude on a cloud meditating like it
is a long-term intentional practice that
when I feel that tension in that room
and I feel my body starting to shut down
get angry get
mad I instantly smile and go what is my
body trying to protect me from or I've
been in an active shooter situation in a
school like I've been in
that I am reacting to training have but
I'm being highly intentional and highly
aware and I'm being curious not
judgmental I know I don't know I'm
terrified right now I'm scared to death
I got my training and I got my cell
phone and I'm gonna do the best take
care of these students that I got that's
being curious what comes next see one is
a posture of response and Madness and
one is a a one of intentionality I
remember talking being around I guess
talking when I was training MMA back in
the day years ago and the guys who moved
on to become professional fighters we
used to always laugh like dude your job
is punching other people in the face for
money like that's a funny job right
always always the calmest guys in the
room the F the chill most like huh and I
remember thinking two things number one
y'all have nothing to prove like you do
this for a living it's what you do you
don't have to walk around flexing
everybody this is this is who this is
what you do and the second thing was the
moment you get emotional in a in a in a
sparring match or in a fight you're
going to lose you get angry you get mad
you get overzealous I'm sure it's that
way you're on the track the moment I get
mad the moment I get out of a game plan
is moment I make a stupid decision and
get myself in trouble the more I can
stay curious the more I can stay
intentional and aware the better things
are going to roll it just feels like
you're not clinched you're not tightened
up so you feel less powerful and so it's
learning to find power and strength in
loosening your grip which sounds
counterintuitive it's all a bunch of
real fun polarities in this reality we
call being human is that is that similar
to driving is that is
that picture myself like getting really
angry about the way
someone's blocking me or something and I
could key up on the radio and start
swearing and getting angry and all it
does is just pull some of my focus it's
a
distraction away from what I need to be
doing so
I could just and I could also take
accountability which is what I'd have to
think in my head and be like it's my job
to get by
them so I'm sucking right now it's my
job to get by them and if I keep
complaining about this I am pulling my
energy in a different direction and it
needs to be all here it need to be look
I need to be figuring out how to do it
so getting rid of distraction is
something that you've said really well
and then taking accountability which is
something that you've said is really
important and then doing the next right
thing right yeah we just take them out
[Laughter]
yeah
exactly um okay um choose uh to choose
health and
healing I love this that's I mean that's
just being pretty direct I mean we
just it's I I can't fathom how it became
taboo to talk about but the Obesity
levels and the metabolic challenges and
the mental health challenges and the
traumas this just run running from
family system to family system to family
system you can do all the right things
man but if your body's not healthy your
body's going to try to get your
attention and let you know they not okay
if you haven't dealt with family trauma
and you haven't been honest with
somebody about the abuse or the whatever
happened um your body's going to
continue to try to get your attention
and scream at you 247 that you're not
safe and so you got to enter into those
spaces where I'm going to own health and
healing and it sucks and you got to go
do it is it very common for someone one
that carries extra weight to actually be
carrying the weight as a subconscious
defense mechanism for rape or abuse from
childhood that it makes them
unattractive so that that it doesn't
happen again is this I I know there's
some there's some definite correlations
between obesity and abuse absolutely I
don't know if it's the attraction or if
it's just creating space right it's just
it's just an ability to hide behind the
curtain just the curtain becomes you
right I haven't looked at that
literature in a long time but it made
maybe this I'm going to intentionally
become unattractive that sounds more
like a backend story to I'm just going
to separate from somebody um I'm gonna
disappear behind you know almost like uh
the old emo kids that had their hair in
front of their face like I'm just gonna
hide behind my hair I'm gonna hide in my
own skin right um but I think bigger
than that is chronic pain my knees hurt
my back hurts my neck hurts I can't go
do these fun things I can't roll around
on the floor with kids and so I think it
may not be the issue in and of itself
clearly it's got Health implications but
it begins to slowly rob you of the
things that do bring you Joy and that's
also my buddy who's a physician who's
got an like a he's told me for five
years and he's G get his neck fixed and
he's grumpy about it and it always hurts
and I'm like dude choose healing go get
your neck fixed you can't roll around on
the floor you can't do this go do the
things that you need to do to take care
of your body well I wonder m question is
about it being actually more of a
parallel example of how much you're
choosing yourself and having autonomy in
your life like the more that you
continue to choose so it's kind of like
a it's running a parallel to your own
internal work is like how well are you
taking care of yourself are you doing
healing and are you doing Health are you
putting junk in your body are you
putting off getting feeling better are
you you know are you ignoring these
things and then essentially being being
a mirror for how you're actually
treating yourself like your inner child
or your your
internal Compass I dude you just nailed
it I think most people that I talk to
across the country most of the
time don't like themselves at all
they're too fat they're not enough
they're not pretty enough they don't
have enough money they don't have
whatever they're not a good enough lover
they just don't have they're not enough
they just don't like themselves and so
why in the hell would I invest in a
company I don't care for I don't like my
buddy s d Stefano he's with the Mind
pump guys out in San Jose just an
amazing guy he's more incredible behind
closed doors as a friend and I I talked
I I was talking to him about I was like
dude I just I've worked out my whole
life I ran track and colle like I'm a
healthy guy what is the deal with not
thinking I'm enough and what's the deal
with like eating and he said something
so profound he said and this is a
personal one-on-one conversation he's
like damn dude you cannot go to the gym
and hate yourself into better shape into
better body if you go to the gym and say
I'm so disgusting I got to work this
disgusting into a less disgusting
form that will run out of gas 100% of
the time if you wake up every day and
you say dude I love myself enough that I
get one hour My Wife and Kids my job
they get the rest but I get one hour
because I'm worth one freaking hour he
goes you'll do that for the rest of your
life and so it that was a a GameChanger
for me is I'm going to choose health and
healing because I'm worth that halfway
through writing this book I had a just a
break I was like dude I'm not living any
of this crap I'm writing about you know
what I mean and I had to go see a trauma
counselor and talk about some stuff I've
never admitted anywhere and work through
that and deal with my relationship with
my seven-year-old little girl and I all
that to say
is halfway through the book is when I
was like dude you go around the country
telling people that they're worth being
well when are you going to believe that
and it was like today I'm GNA stop
trying to hate myself in a better shape
or hate myself into better mental health
I'm gonna stop hating myself into more
friendships I'm worth going to the gym
man I'm worth taking I'm worth not
eating that because I'm not gonna feel
good and dude that has been the
GameChanger of the century for me just
to repeat that to yourself was this
something starting from a place of I'm
worth being loved and I could put
practices into place like how did this
become is that a truth for you do do
today believe wholeheartedly that you
are worth being loved yeah the thing for
me is I've always been an obnoxiously
disciplined guy and so um uh I nodded my
head through joo's book right I was like
well of course yeah yeah so the
discipline part was there it was this it
was never enough because when you don't
like yourself you just keep moving the
Finish Line on your yourself it's like
running a race and you get to the end
and it just keeps going and so if you're
running to try to prove to yourself that
you have value you get to the finish
line and it sucks because you went with
you it's when you say no I'm gonna be a
good Steward of my body and part of that
is going for a run and part of that's
working my ass off so that I can get a
great time and be whatever you're gonna
do but then I cross that finish line and
I can pump my fist and I didn't have to
prove something to myself I already have
proven I I'm already worth Val I already
have value now I'm gonna go do something
crazy and dude it changes the whole game
where did that narrative come from for
you I mean it's a mixture of some pretty
gnarly childhood experiences I think
it's a mixture of having a SWAT hostage
negotiator for a dad who loved me more
than life itself but was raised by a
World War II vet who fought Nazis who
was raised by a guy who died when he was
nine and so I think that's just stuff
goes downhill and know that my dad loved
me and was super proud of me and he's
those words are hard to say out loud and
so now my poor 13-year-old son get I
grab his face every single day of his
life and I stare into his eyes and I
sayi need you to hear me I love you and
I trust you please don't make 13-y old
decisions today but you're 13 I know
you're going right so it's just it's
just changing it over time um but I dude
I don't have any idea if I pinpointed I
just know that I had over time the
ticker tape running underneath the story
of my life was you suck and you're a
piece of crap you're a piece of crap and
it was addressing that narrative that um
has changed everything hell yeah I had a
narrative too is that you're not enough
I mean like came from a series of many
things in childhood of like you're not
fast enough you're not working hard
enough you're not doing enough you're
not enough you're not enough you're not
enough supported by no emotional
awareness because of my mom's patterning
from her like it's just like the book is
there you just open the book to your
parents and you go oh that's the story
of my life right right um I also I also
think um parents get a bad
rap and
I think on the whole most parents are
doing the best they could with the tools
they got 100% super grateful for that
that's I think what that when you said
that it goes from gener look your
parents did better your than your
parents you're doing better than your
parents essentially for like being able
to become more aware and like you know
if you were if your dad was you know if
your dad's dad barely said I love you to
him or like patted him on the back now
your dad at least like patted you on the
back and said I love you son and now
you're strabbing your son's face and
saying I love you you know you're the
best and I'm here for you and you know
like every generation does do better and
I think that's what you realize when you
see the way that it's happened to you is
you go oh my gosh and you get that
insight to going and they did better
than there you know they've really
improved and and then you all of a
sudden go from pissed off to proud
that's right that's right or you have a
parent who struggles with addiction
deeply and you go from I can't believe
you did that and I hate you and you
should have been there for me Fair all
those things are right and fair and then
you go to my God what happened in your
life that that was your body's way of
getting through the day and then you
learn that story and the whole the whole
narrative expands and then you go to a
place of forgiveness and I'm not going
to carry that center block anymore and
is there a way I can create relationship
in this world be like so I think there's
something important about learning your
story and I think you got to go through
the whole mix of being pissed off and
angry and frustrated and I can't believe
that and then you get to the other side
of it which is Grace which
is I can't believe y'all came that far
that's pretty impressive and man and I
gotta make sure I don't overcorrect you
know like parents who like my kid's my
best friend ah don't do that to your
children you're going to destroy your
kids doing that and so I have to let my
kid know he's loved and let him know
that there is not a thing he can do that
he's not welcome back in my house
and I'm gonna hold you accountable man
and I expect you to grow up and I expect
you to do hard hard hard stuff and and
on and on and on right it's both hands
all right well then let's wrap up with
the final one which is the perfect one
just choose belief I want to hear what
you have to think first oh good I love
it by the way you could psych
psychoanalyze me this whole time it's
the funnest thing to me I want to know
about myself I I inter it different than
than than a than a religious Faith or a
or a practice like that for me belief is
more about like when you choose belief
you you you're you have such conviction
about something you're willing to go all
the way like I embody this entire
reality for myself and I know it to be
true and I believe in this like I I will
go to the ends of the Earth for this
like this is this is a truth for me so
so for me that's what I think of when I
when I see belief but in reading reading
I know that that it's more it's more
than that for for what you're trying to
articulate yeah so what I what I was
articulating with it is this simple
practice of this and again I go back to
the evolutionary psychology route like
for all of human history people walked
outside of their tents and they looked
up to the sky and said dear God please
rain or gods or whatever Cosmos
whatever and then over the last couple
hundred years so it's wir into us to
submit it's wired into us to take a knee
that we are a part of something bigger
than
ourselves and overnight we solve for
food most mostly across the world we
solve for water mostly across the world
we've solved for major things that have
plagued Humanity for all human history
right up until a couple hundred years
ago if you got a cut on your leg it
might kill you it it won't anymore right
and in that process of solving for those
challenges we've gotten very very a
arrogant about our role this as a sinner
of the universe and so
my what I'm getting at
is many of the ancient uh not ancient
but the psychological theories end on
this idea of
self-actualization right that you when
you get this and you get this and you
get this and you get this then you reach
this Pinnacle where you are the beacon
on the
hill the world your of your creating
begins to revolve around
you and what I'm suggesting is
psychologically our bodies cannot hold
up the universe we were never designed
to be the center of all
things and when your body recognizes
that the whole world is resting on your
shoulders it will sound every alarm it
has because it cannot hold the self
can't hold and I think it was best
articulated in that just it's now become
just a famous speech by David Foster
Wallace this is water but it he says man
we're beings created to worship and he's
an atheist that wasn't a religious
statement but if you are a being created
to
worship and you worship Beauty you're
never going to be beautiful enough and
you'll always see the little crinkles
around your eyes and around your mouth
and you're always going to be trying to
find the next thing because that's your
God and if you worship money you will
never have enough and if you worship
shiny things and collect things or you
worship trophies there will always be
another trophy to go get and so it it's
this idea of backing out of that rat
race and taking a
knee and submitting like in AA they call
it higher power I'm a Christian guy so
that's like that's I worship God but
what where if you're a Muslim I don't
care what your what Your Faith practice
is what your tradition is I don't even
care if you want to call it higher power
I've got friends who are just incredible
moms and dads and partners and they're
atheist as the day is long and they
believe deeply in the birth and life and
death and Resurrection cycle right I
become part of the soil which becomes
part of the whatever you got to believe
in something bigger than yourself and
ultimately live into something of
service to something bigger than
yourself or you will crash under the
weight of the universe you've
constructed for yourself and so there's
something powerful about taking a knee
and saying dear God please Reign so my
kids can live there's a different way
that you open your hands up and
experience the world versus I'm going to
control every freaking variable of
everything all the time that's anxiety
is it when you do that when you take a
knee and you ask for that is it then
that you you truly take the load off
because you actually you really believe
that someone else is helping you then is
that what lightens the load a great
question I gu probably spend some time
digging into that
um I think the load is simply an a like
I'm not carrying this anymore
and trusting that whatever you have
leaned into has has that yeah whether
you personify it or whether it's an
energy or what like I think there's like
oh this was never mind to carry in the
first place at the end of the day the
only thing I can control are my thoughts
and my actions and that's it and that's
a different level of of weight to carry
I like that I I pray I mean I would call
myself a spiritual person and I think my
angels are badass and all the time like
I'll share this with anybody most badass
Angels I've got they're called Runner
guides my friend Nat told me about this
she's like when you're traveling just
calling your Runner guides you would
believe the things that I
have been able to make happen with those
Runner guides um but that very Act of
prayer is the act of taking a knee and
I'm curious a little bit as just one
more follow-up question is about you
know being you're not the center of the
universe so I just would challenge or be
curious about how a way a way
to look at it differently the way I see
it
is I am like that I do feel like that I
feel like look my reality is but is is
is going to be interpreted by the way
that I have formed my own little little
Universe inside of me like the way that
I have that the way that I see things my
I believe at a fundamental level
perception is reality and that's only
coming from me so in that way my
universe changes like my world changes
my what I see everything I see and
experience changes when I change inside
so in that way I feel like like my call
it my inner child higher self soul is
the Center of My Universe is that
universe that we may be talking
semantics here so we're saying the same
thing just in a different way
the perception of is is the reality that
you're perceiving oh we can get super
nerdy here is the reality that you're
perceiving is there a tethered reality
that exists outside of you so I'm a
constructivist researcher that was my
research way so I believe that off in
reality doesn't matter if I say dude
there's no harm here and your body is
saying scream run right or your body is
calling back you have PTSD and your body
is trying to get your attention I can
yell all day long till I'm blue in the
face about how there's no threat here
what I really need to do is come to you
right but that doesn't change the
reality that there's no threat
here and so the more somebody with
PTSD stays inside that reality that
their body is constructed for them which
is it's all coming down we're not safe
we're reliving this we're reliving this
we're reliving
this the more they crumble under that
weight the more they they begin
to come in touch with the true reality
that exists outside ofs which is there's
no threat here you weren't safe then but
you're safe now right but nothing
changes that's unloading that thing
nothing changes until they change
nothing changes until I like if that
were me inside of you inside of you yeah
I have to change inside like I'm the
universe man like in here it's all in
here nothing is going to change until
this changes I can't talk my way into
thinking that if I hear a bomb it's not
going to remind me of being at you know
serving and at war or something it might
like you can't say like oh it's not it
like every time it goes off it's going
to trigger me like I have to change the
operating system within myself so that
that doesn't happen anymore H how do you
handle somebody who
says
um no I won that race and they're like
you got 33rd you're like no no no no I
won I won I did my best I won and
they're like I know but I would be like
I want some of what you
got but I got but but actually you know
yeah I mean of course there's a well it
kind of leads to another very
interesting topic which is the nature of
objective reality and if we are all are
our own you know have our
own world that we see based on how we
are it really challenges the idea of
objective
except there's a first through 33rd
Place that's very objective right right
does that make
sense like I'm going so fast you're
going 42 miles an hour I'm going so fast
I know in your body it feels like you're
going fast you're only going 42 miles an
hour because I got a clock on you right
so that becomes that objective so then
do I have to take that person 242 miles
an hour so they go oh yeah that wasn't
242 miles an
hour I think you you
can yes I have no business going 242 but
you could teach me I couldn't talk
myself into I know what it feels like to
go 242 you be no you don't let's get in
there and your heart comes out the back
of your spine you're like oh that's what
that that's reality that's what that
feels like that's what I'm saying so I
do think there's a a reality out there I
think where we get into some challenges
is when we use words like scary
descriptive words that's scary that
guy's mean she's too tall she's too big
he's not strong enough that's where you
get into constructed reality sometimes
but in terms of like no you got 33rd
like that to me feels as concrete as the
ground we're driving right and I want
there to be some objective truths man I
don't want you to be like no dude I made
that ground that racetrack I made it
solid right well like what's solid to
you you know what I mean like real solid
yeah yeah it's true we do we we do we do
need that we do need some objective
realities to participate this in this
agreed
upon reality that we live in give me
what is your best Universe book I'm
interested in reading about that
um holographic Universe oh my gosh just
the title alone I'm super in holographic
Universe [__] that you couldn't imagine
like you're like how does that happen
all right I'm in on I really believe
that the nature of reality is so much
more odd than we can we can imagine I
100% believe that yes yes yes yes okay
cool holographic univers why do you
think that um because I think that the I
mean to get nerdy I think the nature of
reality is in the in between I think
we've got really exess obssessed with
looking at each individual atom and I
think the action is between atoms
between molecules
between systems I don't think that the
objective piece is what is nearly as
important as I don't think the
individual people sitting in that row
are nearly as important as What's happen
what they're all doing together and that
changes the nature of what I'm looking
at well it kind of plays into some of
your work in the book and what you're
talking about with a lot of things which
is the non the nonverbal communication
are you like a little bit of the like
literally sitting between two people
like the energy between you can feel
that yeah you know when somebody is
deeply plugged into you or when you're
safe or when your body's like hey it's
time to go we gotta go yeah you know
that I've been saying this for a while
and I'm curious your take on it but I
feel like we're in this really like
interesting point in in time where we're
being asked to really be really tuned
into our bodies we're getting so far out
of our body that the only option is to
go so far back into our body because we
don't even know we don't know when
someone's telling the truth anymore we
don't know if we don't know if something
that we see on the internet is a deep
fake now right we don't really know
right and we don't know if a documentary
we saw was produced and paid for by the
exact people that they want you to buy
their stuff like you
know we don't know and so it's only with
this or inner compass with this tune
into the body that we can actually start
to be able to be a human lie detector
now and get into the in between and feel
into the frequency and the energy that
is all around us and that there's no
such thing as empty space if you're a
leader and you can't say the words I'm
sorry or I changed my mind which I think
are are the four of the most important
words in the English language like why
would you read a book if you already
know how the book ends why would you
read a book about science if you already
agree with what the outcome's going to
be what a stupid waste of your time you
already think why would you do that read
a book that you might disagree with or
you might learn something and then you
could say the magic words I changed my
mind and so if you're a leader and you
can't say I change my mind if you're a
leader and you can't say hey dude I used
to think this and I got more data and
now I learned this then I'm not then you
have lost all credibility with me if you
can't say dude I made some major
mistakes and I thought this was the
right path and we got down it and we
realized that was a wrong path we're
gonna go this way now I I want nothing
to do with you and on the other side if
somebody made a deep fake and it was Joo
and he was saying you know what I think
all this discipline is just kind of bull
crap well I've done events with Joo I
have like walked with jao I've listened
to his stuff I've read his books I would
know that doesn't ring
true right or if it was like dude click
here for deep fake Secret videos of Joo
I I don't choose to have that in my head
I'm not g going to entertain that as a
click right I don't I don't need that in
my head and so to me that's just going
back to that's the intentionality that's
the mindfulness that's what am I feeding
myself you know what I mean and so I I
don't know I I just want to unplug from
the system as much as try to navigate so
what is the future it's a mirage it's a
Sil yeah yeah what is there's so much so
much of that out there you're right so
then what is the what is the what does
the newly constructed world look like if
falls in on itself I mean it it's I the
most compelling argument I've seen so
far there's two compelling arguments one
is that like with AI and stuff it's
going to be a really impressive tool and
it's much to do about nothing it's going
to be amazing it's going to transform
our lives in pretty cool ways and the
same as the guys riding the horses um
were like if you have these cars we're
all going to lose our jobs and you know
and like one guy who his whole family
for Generations created the pooper
scooper that scooped up poo out of the
out of the street this suddenly went
away when the Model T hit the streets
you know what I mean and more jobs than
who could have imagined have created out
of the automotive industry right so it
could be that or I think Neil degrass
Tyson's idea that like dude these deep
fakes will spin on themselves in such a
quick and profound way that it just
shuts the whole thing down it just
becomes noise just static all the time
and then I'm G have to do something
insane
insane I'm gonna have to ask my friend
hey what do you
think what do you think instead of just
Googling it or my neighbor who's a
farmer have you been growing you've been
growing food for I got to tune in yeah I
got to know my neighbors um I gotta
there is a great researcher talking
about apocalypse like when it all goes
down when the grid goes down and I think
it was I think she said the greatest
hedge on quote unquote what comes next
is how closely connected what your are
your relationships with your neighbors
Tada not like how much food prep do you
have how much stored coffee do you have
do you know your neighbors you have a
small group of people that you can get
through the next six to n months or 12
months with that you trust you go get
the food we'll help you all right right
and that becomes the circling it up and
I think that's that's tuning in you know
the human the the human experiment that
happens every year for one week that's
like that what's that burning
[Laughter]
man you know what happened to Burning
Man this year yeah dude yeah I was there
did did did they make it they all rally
together we all totally rallied like if
people needed food or they needed you
know something you know like you all had
to help each other right figure out
that's right you had to figure it out
and it's like this cool social
experiment that happens for one week
every year and they've been just doing
it for decades now and but when that
social experiment like had a Calamity
this year did it did you leave that with
a more optimistic outlook on people
working together yeah totally oh toally
awesome yeah I mean we were trying to
get our Winnebago out and there's guys
that are like covered in mud and with
boards coming over to like put it under
the tire to try and help you go pushing
while getting like totally kicked with
mud and it's like what are you guys
doing oh we're trying to get out of here
too it's like oh and they're like oh if
you guys you know if we're you know like
at one point it was like got stuck
couldn't move they're like all right
well we're just over here we're g to
make some tacos tonight if you want to
come over and you need some food like
the the the social experiment works it
works it's just and it's like what's
actually very interesting about burning
man is that it's like there's
essentially like there's a feeling of
like this crazy freedom of no rules no
nothing everybody does whatever they
want but the
total
like irony of it is it's actually the 10
rules that make it all work it's the 10
rules followed very
closely that actually create the freedom
isn't that funny well it's boundaries
right it's like having a a sounds so
pedantic it's like having a budget
allows you to know how much money you
have so you can spend and buy whatever
you want within those rules it's knowing
I'm in a connected loving relationship
I'm anchored into Bedrock so I can
tether off this thing and be a maniac
because I'm loved it's that same and we
think that freedom is no rules it's
insane that's Insanity it's boundaries
right right and they are very strict
rules it's about inclusiveness it's
about helping it's about cleaning up
after yourself like there's there's 10
very big rules human 101 right yeah yeah
that's awesome very cool yeah I don't
want to open up a can of worms out of
but out of curiosity given the fact that
you know s De stepanos so well and and
but then I just brought up Burning Man
and you do you want to help people feel
better and process their traumas and I
don't know if you know where I'm going
with this but the role of the emerging
role Ro of different kinds of drugs or
plant medicines or medicines that they
play on people you know you know
processing like one of my very one of my
very good friends he owned the company
GoDaddy and he served in the Marines and
it wasn't until he did and I'm not
speaking out of turn these are things
he's happy to talk about and they've
been in magazines like it wasn't until
he did those therapies that he says I
came home
I can't I mean the literature is super
clear my friends with like my close
personal friends who have done that I
mean they just say it was yeah I came
alive I met God I drank for 14 years and
then I haven't drank since years ago I
was a operator in whatever military unit
and I've seen and done some insane
things and now I can hold my baby like
so I think anybody who just misses that
off the table is not looking at the
clinical data right the the the trials
and I I do appreciate that that that
Community is trying to play by the rules
so they can help people and I say
playing by the rules like I'm filing
clinical trials I'm doing these
randomized control stuff so that we can
get it published in the science text so
that we can follow your
rules but just the conversation after
conversation after conversation I have
with people who've been down that road I
I think it would be Madness to throw out
the window well you know in body
feedback my whole body got goosebumps
and that's like the full body yes of
like how much truth there is in that and
that you believe that too you know I
mean I mean you have to it's it's
Madness it would be Madness to just be
like no none of that's real no I've
talked to that dude it's real in fact
not only have I talked to that dude I
was with that person before and now I'm
with that person after and one I'm
thinking of one former operator in
particular I was with that person and
when they laugh I told the the team I
was with I don't want to be around that
person and now I consider that person a
very close friend and so yeah it's a
very different experience very different
experience the landscape of healing is
changing so much it absolutely is and I
go back to the the Andy hberman quote
like Better Living Through science still
requires better living right and so I do
think there's something very powerful
about sitting with somebody
administering this medicine that you
trust that's you submitting it's you
taking the need of somebody and saying I
believe in you please walk with me and
there's the actual experience itself and
then there's the community on the back
end and then there's the well I quit
drinking and six months later I feel
fantastic and I so I think it's all of
it right yeah I was just like thinking
about the six and I'm like you know
there's a lot of those six within the
experience you see you choose reality
you see things you and you see the way
you're in the experience and they're so
real that they're real and they become
embodied then which becomes a new
reality and connection you want to know
yourself so you do it Freedom you're
doing it so that you can know more
you're doing it so you can see things as
they are mindfulness becomes you become
you sort of have an observer awareness
of your experience health and healing is
you're doing it for that and belief you
like like there's so much of all those
every person I've ever met has said that
they walked away they may not walk away
a Christian or walk away under some
fundamental religious belief but like oh
no no no no there's a bigger thing
there's something bigger at Play There's
so something way bigger at play and it's
good and I'm gonna be all right on the
back end a 100% of the people I've
talked to so yeah I'm optimistic that
it's I mean I'm optimistic for any sort
of healing tool that helps anybody right
brings peace and
relief I'm still super Into The Human
Experience and into connectivity and if
there's some barrier that prevents
connectivity then man it's through the
integration afterwards that you know you
have the experience but as I you were
talking about your inner world and your
outer reality not matching and that is
exactly how I describe plant medicine or
those experiences those mod modalities
is that you go into the experience and
right now your inner and outer your in
yourself and your reality kind of match
like your world and you kind of match
you kind of have your friends and your
job and your things and then you go into
the experience it's lifechanging because
you've now in my spiritual terms would
say I'd say like skip timelines you've
skipped a lot of timelines or you've
just changed so much you have new
embodied beliefs and truths that now
your outer reality really doesn't match
where you're at anymore and it takes
time and it's in that time and that
integration of getting to that new
reality that you've or whatever way you
want to look at it right right right
right right whatever youever what
direction um but it's in that it's in
that process that that is what you're
talking about which is in the connection
which is in the people which is in the
the the the communication which is in
the the sober exercise in yeah in
exercise and in movement and carrying
with your friends and eating well I it's
all that stuff all wound together it's
beautiful thank you very much and
congratulations on the book and uh it's
awesome thank you for your ality dude
you're awesome thank
you thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense